so the world's body that governs
swimming it's called fina has finally
banned men from competing in women's
swimming events took a while but there's
a catch the new rule applies only to men
who started their quote transition to
as if that's possible after the age of
12
so in other words if parents decide to
chemically castrate a major male child
at a young age
then the body will allow that
man to compete against women when they
get older
huh what effect is this going to have
well rally gains has thought a lot about
it rally games is an ncaa swimmer swim
against leah thomas she joins us tonight
riley thanks so much for coming on so
you've been almost single-handedly
bringing this topic to public attention
many of your
fellow swimmers are embarrassed so thank
you for doing it again how how do you
feel about this ruling
i definitely think it's a step in the
right direction it's a bold first step
obviously it's not everything we need
more organizations across a bunch of
different sports to comply as well but i
think it's a very bold first step and i
think it's something worth celebrating
does that view reflect that of people
you swim with do other swimmers feel
that i mean you're the sort of lens
through which we understand swimming
because again everyone else is afraid to
come on tv and talk about it but do you
know people who agree with you
yes i do for sure being someone who
witnessed that firsthand being at that
competition in in march i saw the amount
of tears shed the extreme discomfort in
the locker rooms you know the talk of
anger and frustration and so i
definitely think that you know i'm
speaking for a large majority here
so parents in the ottoman empire a lot
of them castrated their sons in the hope
they would grow up to be the court
eunuch which is a position of real
powers real benefit to castrating your
children in the ottoman empire i wonder
if this ruling doesn't set up
a potential incentive for parents to
give their young boys massive hormone
treatments pre-puberty
right it's worth noting i think that you
know having this set age will it sway
children you know will it encourage
parents
personally i think it's unlikely just
because maybe i don't have much
experience you know seeing those kinds
of things and so
that's why i do think this is a step in
the right direction but it's definitely
you know kind of worth taking into
account
that strict age that they set it's um
yeah a little scary
last question i've and i meant to ask
you this before but
why haven't more coaches spoken out
about these people who devoted their
lives to women's swimming and they're
seeing this cheating going on and yet i
haven't heard any of them say a word
about it in public why
uh right i think it's because obviously
we live in this this kind of canceled
culture
i think they fear for their jobs you
know they have higher ups above them who
you know could be intimidating them or
threatening them and so i think that
they're scared um to speak out about it
but you know the more voices whether it
be athletes coaches um non-athletes it
really matters and so to have those
voices it really weighs a lot
yeah it does and yours does i hope
you're rewarded someday for your bravery
riley thank you for joining us i mean it
thanks thank you
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight